[Música]
hola qué tal yo soy sandra echeverría y
mi plática de hoy se llama rompiendo los
estereotipos
recuerdo ya hace varios años cuando yo
empezaba mi carrera me mandaron mis
mánagers en esa época a una audición y
con la vulnerabilidad esa inseguridad y
el terror con el que uno llega a los
estudios hice mi casting para un
proyecto y me dijeron es que tienes
demasiada ceja es que no eres tan
delgada es que no representas a la
belleza que buscamos en nuestras
protagonistas
eso entre muchas cosas más y después de
hacer mi escena me dijeron es que tu
forma de actuar es demasiado natural y
nosotros en las novelas hacemos todo un
poco más exagerado te tengo que poner un
coach para que lo hagas como nos gusta
en esta empresa
me quedé en shock yo no quería que me
depilar a las cejas ni quería que me
cambiaron mi color de pelo ni quería
cambiar mi forma de actuar por entrar
dentro de un estereotipo de una empresa
yo no era eso yo era mucho más que eso
una actriz que había estudiado
yo me consideraba una actriz preparada
me había mudado hace unos años a los
ángeles para estudiar formalmente como
actriz pero al ver que buscaba en otra
cosa preferí echarme para atrás y no
buscar más oportunidades ahí
tiempo después me llamo otra empresa y
justo buscaban a alguien sé hong como yo
con facciones latinas árabes de tez
morena clara pelo oscuro y con mi estilo
de actuar de una forma mucho más
realista más natural como me enseñaron a
mí durante tantos años era justo el
proyecto que yo deseaba y fue ahí donde
cambió mi vida es el clon una novela que
me abrió las puertas a muchos países
donde mi nombre se dio a conocer a
partir de ahí después de haber
comprobado que a pesar de que no era la
belleza que buscaban en algunos lados
hay cupo perfecto y no eso
habíamos logrado ser un hit y romper
récords de audiencia después del éxito
del clon todo cambió ya me buscaban
varias empresas para protagonizar ya no
importaba que mis ojos fueran obscuros y
viseras de intensas solo importaba que
yo había logrado tener un éxito tiempo
después me regresé a los ángeles y me
encontré con que esa industria gigante
solamente estaba hecha de estereotipos
que no veían más allá la latina tenía
que ser latina la asiática tenía que ser
asiática tenga que tener rasgos
asiáticos tenía que tener rasgos latinos
una latina no podía ser un personaje de
abogada ni de policía
la latina representaría siempre lo que
es me di cuenta de que en mi país
tendría mucho más oportunidad de hacer
cosas arriesgadas e incluso de producir
proyectos de crear el personaje que yo
quisiera para mí sin etiquetas sin
estereotipos fue ahí donde me animé a
producir mi primera película me tardé
siete años en lograrlo pero logré
levantar la historia que yo quería
contar con el personaje que yo buscaba
hacer y fue ahí donde nació busco novio
para mi mujer
los estereotipos están por todos lados
incluso me ha pasado con la música yo
empecé cantando a mis 9 años música
ranchera mexicana pero siempre hubo este
estereotipo de no creció en un rancho es
que no viene de los fernández ni de los
aguilar y yo solamente respondía pues no
pero vengo de los echeverría aunque no
sean famosos somos mexicanos y gracias a
ellos heredé el amor y la pasión por la
música mexicana mi carrera y yo creo que
la de muchos que nos están escuchando
siempre se ha visto antagoniza da por
los estereotipos y ahí es donde uno debe
de analizar si realmente está uno
dispuesto a perder su propia esencia
estás dispuesto a perderla para entrar
dentro de la industria o lo que tu
carrera te pide estás dispuesto a
perderte a ti mismo
hace varios años en mi país no me
dejaban hacer cine porque empecé mi
carrera haciendo el gas y el hacer
novelas era satanizado por el gremio del
cine porque bueno está el estereotipo de
que si eres actriz de novelas entonces
eres mala actriz y yo debo defender ese
punto porque las actrices de televisión
hacen de 20 a 30 escenas al día y deben
de ser capaces de entrar situación
inmediatamente deben tener una memoria
privilegiada y llevar la continuidad de
20 a 30 escenas al día
para mí el haber arrancado como actriz
de novelas fue lo que me dio a mí mejor
escuela debo decirlo y mi graduación fue
el haber hecho hasta tres audiciones en
inglés al día audiciones tras audiciones
en un idioma que ni siquiera era el mío
y el haber sido rechazada en el 99% de
ellas pero bueno en ese 1% de proyectos
en los que sí me quedé tuve la suerte de
conseguir un papel importante en una
película que se llama salvajes con
oliver style
después de eso tuve mi primer propuesta
para hacer cine en mexico es así tuve
que trabajar primero allá para que me
dieran oportunidades en méxico
yo vengo a hablar de mis experiencias y
de lo que ha ido aprendiendo sobre lo
importante que es el amor propio y para
eso siempre he dicho que es importante
darnos nuestros propios entonces para
vernos al espejo y analizar nuestro
paquete y al decir paquete me refiero a
ver y analizar el ser humano que eres a
la hija la madre a la actriz la esposa a
la cantante lo que sea que tú seas y
agradecer por todo aquello que tenemos
la salud el trabajo nuestra apariencia
física y también la belleza interior
porque tratar de ser alguien más porque
tratar de imitar a alguien más yo soy
una mujer que me gusta admirar a otras
mujeres buscó inspiración en otras
mujeres admiro a cada mujer que tengo en
mi vida
pregúntate qué quieres hoy qué quieres
en 5 años qué quieres en 10 años
sé congruente con lo que hablas con lo
que piensas con cómo actúas con tus
sueños sé impecable con tus palabras
honra te a ti mismo
[Aplausos]
si eres auténtico te hace respetable
ante los ojos de los demás y ante ti
mismo conviértete en esa persona que tú
puedes admirar en esa persona que
también puede aplaudir el éxito ajeno y
como diría don miguel ruiz en los cuatro
acuerdos lo que sueñas lo que sientes y
lo que realmente eres lo muestras por
medio de las palabras y yo también ahí
tendría que agregar de tus acciones
creo que si yo hubiera aceptado cambiar
mi forma de ser física o mi técnica
actoral en el momento de aquella
audición y hubiera seguido las
peticiones de aquella productora muy a
pesar de mí hoy tendría otra carrera
debo realmente parecerme a alguien para
tener éxito para ser feliz
y aquí entro dentro de un tema que nos
ha metido a todos en una exigencia de
perfección las redes sociales
las redes sociales nos muestran casi
siempre una máscara de la vida de las
personas vemos su mejor ángulo los
mejores momentos de su vida los momentos
que todos quisiéramos tener viajes por
el mundo vestimentas perfectas cuerpos
perfectos vidas perfectas retos a
cuántas personas a cuántas personas
conocemos que han sido afectadas
psicológicamente por las redes sociales
alta el grado de perder su vida de
perder el sentido común
hace unos meses leí la historia de una
mujer que a sus 30 años perdió la vida
eso pasó apenas ahora en diciembre
después de someterse a una cirugía y por
qué porque ella se quería aparecer a kim
kardashian
otra mujer de 27 años sometida a más de
20 cirugías invertido más de 500 mil
dólares también para parecerse a kim
kardashian estos fenómenos no que de
repente se ponen de moda y todos quieren
parecerse a ella porque piensan que esa
es la perfección creo que las redes
sociales se ha convertido en un arma de
doble filo hoy en día se han vuelto
imprescindibles para cualquier empresa
es realmente una carta de presentación
son de gran ayuda para muchas cosas pero
por el otro lado creo que nos han
convertido en esclavos porque buscamos
tener aquella vida perfecta que nos
muestran en fotos porque deseamos tener
ese cuerpo perfecto queremos tener ese
auto perfecto
queremos y deseamos ser alguien más
consumir más y de repente ya nada es
suficiente queremos ese estereotipo de
vida
por el otro lado nos exponemos a recibir
bullying las redes sociales porque al
exponernos públicamente hace que
cualquiera pueda opinar que cualquiera
puede llegar a destruirse física y
psicológicamente una persona que jamás
conocerás en tu vida ahora está opinando
sobre tu cuerpo o tu vida dejándote un
hueco de inseguridad no tiene sentido
por eso mi propuesta hoy es romper los
estereotipos
tengamos orgullo de ser quienes somos
trabajemos en el amor propio si tú estás
bien la gente a tu alrededor va a estar
bien agradece tu vulnerabilidad
eso te inyecta de fuerza de coraje de
creatividad y sobre todo no dejes que
nadie te haga de menos las cadenas de
buena onda hace equipo con otras mujeres
las envidias y la competencia solamente
dejan sentimientos negativos en ti te
generan ansiedad enojo inseguridad
reconciliarte con la idea de unirte a
más mujeres con el agradecimiento con el
apoyo de mujer a mujer y verás como todo
se multiplica positivamente
creo que todos en algún momento de
nuestras vidas nos hemos preguntado por
qué le tocó a ella y no a mí
porque se lo dieron a ella porque ya
tiene esto y yo no y el pasar de los
años te das cuenta de que cada quien
tiene su momento que todas esas
preguntas que te hacían no permitían que
te vieras a ti mismo que estabas
demasiado tiempo distraído viendo lo que
los demás eran lo que los demás hacían o
no hacían cada quien tiene cualidades
diferentes cada quien tiene tiempos
diferentes y prioridades diferentes
y pasa el tiempo y te das cuenta de que
tal vez yo vine esta vida por una razón
diferente a la que las demás personas
con la que nos comparábamos hace tiempo
y piensas porque gaste tanta energía en
eso ya no tiene sentido
definitivamente las prioridades van
cambiando conforme vas creciendo y
aprendiendo a través de las experiencias
los estereotipos terminan siendo
obstáculos en nuestras vidas en nuestros
trabajos los estereotipos hacen pedazos
nuestra seguridad nos impiden sacar
nuestra verdadera esencia nuestra
creatividad
romper estereotipos es también prevenir
el maltrato dejar a un lado el machismo
quitarnos esta idea de ser seres
inferiores los estereotipos nos impiden
ser lo que verdaderamente queremos ser
y los estereotipos empiezan en casa
porque un niño debe vestirse de azul y
una niña de rosa porque las pelotas
deben ser para los niños y las clases de
baile deben ser para las niñas
condicionamos a nuestros hijos hacer lo
que la sociedad nos dicta metí a mi hijo
a clases de baile porque ama a michael
jackson y cuando yo hable a la academia
pedí un maestro de hip hop e
inmediatamente me preguntaron de qué
edad estuve y yo contesté es niño y ama
bailar igual en mi condominio invite a
más mamás a la clase pensando que sería
mucho más divertido una clase con varios
niños y contestaron de qué edad es tu
hija y voy a contestar es niño llama a
bailar creo que nosotros como padres
tenemos la responsabilidad de ofrecer a
nuestros hijos aquello que les apasiona
sin importar el qué dirán sin importar
cuáles son los estereotipos para evitar
que tu hijo sea criticado de alimentar
su seguridad para crear generaciones más
seguras más empoderadas y que en un
futuro se puedan dedicar a lo que más
aman creo que en lugar de aspirar ser la
siguiente kim kardashian o la siguiente
angelina jolie
de la mejor versión de ti mismo déjanos
verte a ti con tus defectos y sus
virtudes
eso es lo más auténtico lo más real eso
es lo que queremos ver lo que queremos
leer historias reales trabajos
auténticos tiene éxito aquel que hace
cosas distintas
aquel que realmente hace las cosas desde
el amor y la pasión aquel que se
arriesga aquel que rompe los
estereotipos
[Aplausos]
todos tenemos un imaginario que no
sabotea y nos lleva a ser nuestros
peores jueces es que no soy lo
suficientemente buena es que soy incapaz
es que soy tonta es que no son lo
suficientemente talentosa es que nadie
lo logra nunca lo voy a conseguir
estamos acostumbrados a escuchar lo ya
creerlo a repetirlo constantemente
nuestra cabeza nos hacemos pedazos solos
nos rechazamos a nosotros mismos como
esperamos tener éxito cuando no
rechazamos nosotros mismos no tiene
sentido pero también tenemos a nuestro
ser interior que siempre nos dice la
verdad el problema es que raramente lo
escuchamos
confía en ti confía en tu instinto con
el tiempo irás comprobando que tenía
razón
[Aplausos]
habría que hacer una plática entera
sobre mujeres que yo admiro y que han
sido capaces de romper todos los
estereotipos y que además son super
exitosas arrancando con mujeres
mexicanas alondra de la parra directora
de orquesta gabriela león ingeniera
química mayra gonzález y o de nissan en
méxico martha ortiz chef alí garnero es
maestra de ingeniería aeroespacial
y muchas más bueno hablando de mujeres
que los han roto
internacionalmente está oprah winfrey
está ellen degeneres ashly graham lady
gaga y a mí me encanta poner de ejemplo
a lady gaga porque es un gran ejemplo de
mujer exitosa una mujer segura que ha
roto todos los estereotipos y es por eso
que yo la admiro tanto
[Aplausos]
es una mujer real que defiende su propia
esencia que defiende su belleza natural
sus ideas radicales que busca siempre
sorprender haciendo cosas distintas que
busca siempre hacer lo inesperado segura
de su belleza de ser mujer de su talento
de su cuerpo segura de ella en todas sus
facetas con la seguridad propia de
unirse y hacer equipo con otras mujeres
y con la seguridad de presentarse en
diferentes pesos
siempre segura de ella misma de su
cuerpo en sus diferentes formas yo nunca
he visto a lady gaga sufrir porque está
arriba o abajo de su peso ni siquiera he
visto a la gente juzgarla ella se
muestra tan segura que es imposible
meterse con ella y eso yo lo admiro
tanto no es fácil estar en el foco del
mundo entero cuántas veces nos hemos
sentido juzgadas por nuestro peso si
estás arriba o abajo de lo que
deberíamos estar
en mi carrera siempre fui criticada por
eso si estaba arriba de lo que debería
estar entonces yo tenía que bajar me
condiciona van a ser tallados para
llegar a ser protagonista y siempre
sufrí por eso desde la adolescencia me
la pasé en un sube y baja siempre bajo
la presión del trabajo y después de
tener a mi hijo me pasó al revés empecé
a recibir bullying de que yo estaba muy
flaca que me veía en los huesos que me
veía mal la gente es muy cruel porque no
se ponen a pensar en lo duro que es
tener un hijo en todo lo que pasamos las
mujeres desde el parto lo poco que
duermes los primeros meses en que llevas
alimentando un bebé cada tres horas el
agotamiento y la lactancia a veces te
suben de peso y otras veces te bajan
pero el estereotipo que vemos en redes
sociales es el parís y verte fabulosa y
fuerte como si nada hubiera pasado y si
no es así entonces te critican y te
juzgan esa no es una realidad la
realidad es lo que cada uno vive
diferentes experiencias y no se vale ser
juzgada no se vale que te hagan sentir
mal por los cambios de tu cuerpo ni por
como decides vivir tus propias
experiencias no te dejes
como mujer adulta mi responsabilidad
ahora es pasar a nuevas generaciones
este mensaje de respeto hacia ti hacia
tus ideales hacia tu persona el quitarte
el miedo de mostrarte como tú eres de
animarte a romper con todos los
estereotipos no puedes dejar que nadie
como ser o que no debes de ser mi
responsabilidad ahora con mi hijo es
respetar sus ideales sus sueños
enseñarle a tener absoluto respeto hacia
los demás para que en un futuro sea un
hombre seguro pleno y respetuoso
te invito a que tú mismo rompas todos
los estereotipos que te han impuesto no
dejes que el miedo limite tu potencial
tienes mucho que dar da ese primer paso
las cosas no te van a llegar hay que
buscarlas siempre siendo fiel a ti mismo
te invito a escuchar temas de hacerte
escuchar te invito a admirar temas ya
valorar temas no tengas miedo de poner
límites ante los demás te invito a que
te animes a ser más equipo apoya a otras
mujeres hace ese experimento y ya me
contarás cómo te vas sintiendo hoy
decidí romper los estereotipos y me puse
tenis con un pantalón sastre y una
playera hay que arriesgarse